place à un autre match politique
celui-là il va opposer bernard tapie à
jean marie le pen dans le cadre de la
compétition des élections européennes
c'est le troisième débat organisé par la
rédaction de france 2 demain vous aurez
sur le même plateau philippe de villiers
et bernard kouchner et la semaine
prochaine de valérie giscard d'estaing
affrontera michel rocard également dans
le journal de 20h donc vous le voyez l
occasion de ces cinq débats toutes les
sensibilités sont représentent elles ont
été ou le seront mais si je ne sais pas
si ce mot sensibilité vous convient
peut-être un peu trop un peu trop faible
vous avez des battu une première fois à
tf1 c'était en 89 j'avais vu ce débat
que les français d'ailleurs l'avez vu
ils se souviennent de ce débat houleux
vous avez échangé des noms d'oiseaux
vous avez presque failli en venir aux
mains alors comme je m'en souviens j'ai
pris des jets privés quelques
précautions
grâce à la gentillesse de décathlon ça
coûte rien à la maison en velin alors on
sait jamais si ça se passe mal comme on
veut éviter des traumatismes des coups
sûrs a les gants pour la noue l'autre
si ça se passe mal vous pouvez les
utiliser alors le problème c'est que ma
fidèle gisèle et chez décathlon et la
gentillesse de me prêter mais il y avait
plus qu'une seule couleur c'est leur
engagement on ne garde pas non non non
les rangs de mafate cadeaux pas de
cadeau et interruption
donc c'est la même couleur mais en fait
moi je vous reconnaîtrez alors il ya
vous intéressez tellement les français
et les médias qu'un homme a consacré un
livre au à la fois tapis le club voilà
les jumeaux du populisme c'est thierry
saussez qui a écrit ce livre en
1992 aux éditions numéro un je vais
commencer par l'ordre alphabétique
jean marie jean marie le pen
populisme ça veut dire quoi pour vous
attendez avant avant de vous poser de
questions est-ce que vous allez les
utiliser à votre avis ou par non non
nous n'avons pas utilisé n'en avons pas
besoin mais je les aurais accepté si on
en avait fait cadeau je vois que la
générosité d'antenne 2 ne va pas jusque
1 pas uniquement à petit effet de
tribune parce qu'il ya là entre les en
politique et nous bernard tapie donc
attention également pacifique sérieux la
politique
alors la politique le populisme c'est
quoi pour vous est ce que vous sentez
populistes comme dit eh bien le vrai
problème dans le temps modernes c'est
que chacun utilise ou que tous utilisent
les mêmes mots avec les même
signification or une des grandes raisons
qui n'a sans doute la fin de la tour de
babel c'est que les gens ne se
comprenaient pas et on peut très bien ne
pas se comprendre en utilisant la même
langue et les mêmes mots si populisme
est employé de façon péjorative
comme généralement il l'est par les
observateurs de la politique à l'égard
des hommes politiques bien je ne me
reconnais pas dans cette définition car
le programme
300 mesures que nous présentons est un
programme sérieux qui est très éloignée
de la démagogie puisqu'il réclame au
pays de la lucidité du courage de
l'effort si en revanche populisme veut
dire
interprétation des sentiments du peuple
défense du peuple en quelque sorte le
rôle qui était celui autrefois du tribun
de la plèbe sur à rome dans la rome
antique et ben moi je veux bien accepter
je suis d'origine populaire et j'ai
passé ma vie dans la politique a essayé
de défendre des intérêts du peuple
français avant d'en venir là tapie sur
ce thème dont simplement la définition
donnée par le dictionnaire de la pensée
politique chez hatier populisme appel au
peuple contre l'élite souvent aussi
contre les étrangers et les marginaux
ont verrouillé vous sentez populiste
bernard tapie
oui moi je crois qu'effectivement on
veut dire surtout démagogue mais il ya
effectivement un danger si je comprends
bien les définitions qui sont souvent
utilisés
ce sont ceux qui voudraient un moment
donné de leur vie capter l'opinion
publique pour leur donner pour leur
demander le pouvoir en s'étant fait une
réputation ou en ayant une notoriété qui
n'a rien à voir avec la politique je
pense là à berlusconi qui quand il
faisait du football était mon ami le
reste pour le football est un peu moins
pour la politique parce que là je crois
qu'il ya un piège important je crois
qu'il ya un piège important c'est de
séduire des gens sur des éléments
d'apparence en tout cas où sur des
performances qui n'ont rien à voir avec
la politique est là où je me ressens pas
c'est qu'il me semble que le parcours
qu'il faut faire celui qui consiste à
passer par les étapes intermédiaires
avant de demander un accès fort un
pouvoir fort je crois que je les fais je
les fais avec des gens qui sont
identifiés avec des alliés qui sont
connus avec des mots qui sont utilisés
par mois toujours de la même manière et
en votant tout le temps d'un même côté
c'est à dire qu a pas de surprise celui
qui aujourd'hui votre pour moi c'est
pour qui je vote quelles sont les idées
donc pas y avoir d'interprétation de
transfert de popularité alors vous êtes
deux bêtes de télévision tous les deux
on l'a assez dit et on l'a on l'a déjà
vu vous avez des projets différents d
horizons différents mais au fond vous
chasser sur les mêmes terres je ne crois
pas si ici la terre général si j'ose
dire c'est le peuple français si nous
cherchons à obtenir sa confiance son
soutien et la délégation de pouvoir
qu'il détient pour accéder au
gouvernement
oui bien évidemment mais je crois que
on peut le faire d'une façon
parfaitement honnête loyal droite et que
c'est cela l'objectif que je poursuis et
que poursuivre les les candidats de la
liste alors évidemment mon rôle c'est de
lancer des pistes moi j'ai pas de casque
un seul arbitre donc ça mes risques et
périls même si des coups pleuvent de
tous les côtés mais évidemment vous êtes
autorisé à vous parler très timoré pour
l'instant l'un vis-à-vis de l'autre mais
vous êtes autorisé bernard tapie a cité
le nom de berlusconi tout à l'heure qui
est maintenant chef du gouvernement en
italie avec des miss néofascisme son
gouvernement jean marie le pen si je
vous dis néo fasciste est ce que c'est
pour vous une insulte win pour moi ça ce
n'est pas du tout correspond pas du tout
à la réalité
je crois même qu en italie on n'utilise
pas cet adjectif à l'égard des députés
du msi ou de l'alliance nationale il n'y
a qu'en france qu'on utilise cette
formule je crois qu'il est déraisonnable
de le faire parce que je connais fini
qui est un homme qui est né vous êtes
proche délai vous sentez proche de lui
un temps après la guerre et qui enfin
quinze ans après la guerre et qui est un
homme qui est de la droite nationale qui
a des idées qui sont proches en effet de
celles du front national mais qui n'ont
rien à voir avec le facisme oui tout à
l'heure vous avez posé la question qui
me paraît essentiel c'est de savoir si
on chasse sur les mêmes terres et j'ai
le sentiment qu'elle a beaucoup qui
voudraient nous voir comme ça sur les
mêmes terres parce que je crois que ça
les arrange en réalité sur ce que
j'entends sur ce que je vois sur ce que
je crois comprendre
je crois que pas deux hommes politiques
en france sont aussi dissemblables est
aussi opposée je veux dire que on peut
avoir de temps en temps comme c'est la
mode des envies consensuelles d envie de
faire un bout de chemin ensemble et je
crois que
l'adversaire de soi me contredira pas je
pense que les deux qui peut vraiment pas
faire un bout de chemin ensemble pour un
jour se rencontrer en tout cas sur la
manière de concevoir la france et les
méthodes pour la sortir de la situation
dans lequel elle est c'est en tout cas
le front national et les radicaux par
conséquent que vous ayez ou qu on est en
vie quelque part dans les structures
politiques classiques envie de nous
mettre dans le même wagon ne serait ce
que nous présentons je sais pas si vous
ferez ça avec d'autres candidats non
parce qu'ils n'ont pas voté m parce
qu'ils n'ont pas votre attitude on peut
avoir votre retour on peut avoir
beaucoup de vitalité on peut avoir
beaucoup d'énergie on peut avoir envie
de défendre ses nuits très fort est-ce
qu'on fait normalement alors pour vous
dire tout on n'est pas du tout sur les
mêmes terres parce que ce qui est
certain c'est que ceux qui sont séduits
par les idées de jean marie le pen
peuvent pas de cellule par les haines et
vice et versa je crois donc on est très
près leur poser on va parler des idées
ce soir à
un mot un nom un nom quel est votre
modèle politique pas forcément
oui patrick du niveau je pense que c'est
jules ferry
jean marie le pen oui ce sont les
différents l'écran dirigeants de la
france les grands soldats les grands
héros de l'histoire de la nation mais je
n'ai pas un modèle particulier j'intègre
l'ensemble de l'histoire on a parlé tout
à des neuf à six italiens mussolini
c'est pas un modèle non pas du tout
contrairement aux néo fascistes étaient
les culots rendu hommage récemment le
cinéma ce n'est pas mon cas ça
d'ailleurs que je suis contre les formes
d'intégration européenne c'est parce que
je crois que chacun de nos peuples a une
spécificité qui justement ne venait pas
ne doit pas être fusionnée avec celle
des autres sous peine de nous faire
porter le chapeau des uns des autres ce
que je ne souhaite pas du tout je
voudrais dire une petite chose avant le
débat c'est que
moi je suis prêts bien sûr à rencontrer
tous les têtes de liste c'est une
formule démocratique
je regrette simplement que les têtes de
liste de l'opposition et de la majorité
se soient mis hors de portée du débat
avec ce qui pourrait les critiques et
j'ai vu le débat entre monsieur rocard
et monsieur baudis disons que c'est un
débat convenu et qui s'est terminée en
feu d'artifice sur les conditions de
travail du personnel de la mairie de
conflent et de la mairie de toulouse
alors je crois que le débat européen des
élections européennes vaut mieux que ça
mais je crois qu'ils se sont mis à
l'abri mais grâce à monsieur tapie j'ai
là à symbole somme toute de la gauche il
est emblématique me semble-t-il de la
gauche avec son passé et et quelquefois
assez ces grandes faiblesses nessma et
moi je crois que je suis emblématique la
france je crois que ce tapis c'est la
non france et
jean représente la liste de la france
voilà heureusement que les millions de
francs des millions et je crois plus de
ce côté là que de l'autre on le poils
qui se dressent quand vous dites que
vous êtes la france moi je vais vous
dire pourquoi je vous laisse là je le
voulais et je le voulais vraiment fort
parce que la première fois que nous
sommes rencontrés je pense franchement
que jean marie le pen était un danger
pour la france en tant que tel lui tout
seul et je le pensais parce que mes
convictions m'amène à penser que la
façon dont le fonds national veut gel à
la france est un danger et il était en
montée il ya une croissance forte le
fonds national et est le vent en poupe
il y avait il portait toujours remporté
degli toi les victoires et ça passait de
bon et alors il y avait surtout un
militantisme de basques qui me faisait
peur et puis bon il est effectivement
stationnés aux alentours de 10 non non
non non non 11h 12h sauf lors de la
dernière élection et russell mais c'est
pire s'étaient jurés et à ramener en
dessous de 10% dix-huit mois après nous
étions à 13 à
2 pour son prêt en tout cas pas
suffisamment pour battre les partis
démocratiques pour républicain qui
serait en mesure d'assurer le pouvoir
puisque personne veut s'associer avec
lui et c'est tant mieux vous dire
aujourd'hui vous reconnaissez que vous
défendiez aujourd'hui de l'établissement
là je défendrai de retour et il a tous
les partis contre
le parti communiste là par contre voilà
pourquoi il faut faire ce débat parce
que monsieur le pen monde pas tellement
dans son parti politique mais ces idées
se vendent bien et elles se vendent
tellement bien qu'elles sont plus en
plus reprises alors là je commence à
avoir la trouille de nouveau parce que
si mais monsieur le pen est à 12% qu'est
ce qu'on voit en ce moment on voit les
copies les le pen canada dry qui
commence à venir et à faire eux aussi
des gros scores sur les mêmes idées sur
les mêmes valeurs alors évidemment on
est un peu plus en 10 manches et on a
une carte de visite qui éventuellement
est plus séduisante en temps on se
rassure mais de villiers je suis allé
voir moi aidez moustache une fausse
perruque j'ai entendu ma parole
d'honneur je vous assure j'ai entendu la
même chose la même chose je vois beau
disque était un pro européens
fédéralistes fort il est plus pro
européen du tout il ay même se dégonfle
de parler de l'europe en tant que tu
fédéral
vous avez les lois pasqua c'est
l'inspiration direct sur le pen vous
avez actuellement même chevènement qui
commence à parler de la même fait la
même manière j'ai entendu un premier
socialiste à me dit est ce que c'est son
rôle même si c'est vrai la france peut
pas supporter toute la misère du monde
est ce que c'est un premier ministre
socialiste qui doit dire ça par
conséquent dans un pays où ces idées
commencent à se développer avec une
telle ampleur j'ai de nouveau peur et
j'ai de nouveau père c'est pour ça que
je veux qu'on parle des idées et pas
avec un gant de boxe je veux dire voilà
pourquoi c'est dangereux voilà comment
il faut faire autrement c'est pas
monsieur le pen que je crains c'est ce
qu'ont pris ces idées et qui ont répondu
c'est une dans la france vous allez vous
devez boire du petit lait parce qu'ils
me prête une influence considérable
est ce qui vous arrive vous à très
malade d'aller dans les meetings des
autres avec une petite moustache
non je n'ai pas du tout goût pour ce
genre de comédie je voudrais dire que il
est vrai que fur et à mesure que les
événements évoluent je crois vers des
solutions dramatique sinon ne change pas
de politique eh bien les français et les
hommes politiques qui espère capter leur
voix copie le discours du front national
il y en a qui le copie de façon presque
intégral mais on sait que leur objectif
tactique c'est d'essayer d'empêcher le
le plus de voix possible d'échapper à la
liste de la majorité et de venir sur
celles du front national et puis il y a
d'autres candidats qui changent pendant
la campagne leur axe de campagne c'est
le cas du chef de l' de la liste de la
majorité qui en effet était maastricht y
en ait qui de crainte de voir ces voies
diminué a pris un virage alors que
monsieur tapie lui il prend le virage
exactement inverse mais vous même
monsieur tapie vous avez écrit un livre
qui s'appelle de l'énergie pour l'europe
et vous avez un titre de liste de
l'énergie pour l'europe mais sur vos
panneaux vous coller des affiches de
l'énergie pour la france n'est ce pas
vous avez vous aussi vous avez vous eu
ça n'a rien à voir vous avez vous aussi
subi la fluence et dangereuse souplesse
je ne ferai plus le jour ou non la
récente et c'est bien possible ça mais
c'est peut-être plus proche qu'on ne
peut pas hésité pour les rossonneri
différence absolue de parler de sa crue
avec car en fin de compte en fin de
compte qu'elle est la grande différence
on va parler après du détail mais
manning rome il ya une grande il ya deux
façons moi j'essaie de comprendre
pourquoi la france qui s'était fait
connaître dans le monde entier dans le
monde entier encore maintenant quand on
fait des sondages sur le monde et qu'on
leur dit aux gens quel que soit leur
nation où aimeriez vous vivre en dehors
de votre propre prix tous désignent la
france sans exception
tellement cet affront une france qui a
marqué par sa tradition d'accueil de
générosité de convivialité et de bonheur
voilà que cette france aujourd'hui quand
on regarde la réalité d'abord quand on
les voit dans la rue sont tristes sont
maussades sont découragés n'y croit plus
on appelle ça la déprime mais ça se
matérialise par des éléments objectifs
c'est que la france est maintenant le
pays qui utilise le plus
d'antidépresseurs du monde dire que la
france du petit canon conclu entre amis
est devenue la france du mayon est
pourquoi les deux venus de france junior
et bien parce qu'on lui fait perdre sa
confiance oui et monsieur le pen n'a
cessé et on en parle et après parce que
j'ai n'a cessé d'expliquer fois qu'elle
est malade qu'elle est malade il ya plus
de talent qu'elle est foutue qu'elle est
envahie par les immigrés que c'est la
fin du monde et j'ai même entendu c'est
bientôt sa mort j'ai entendu ça
c'est bien évidemment la constatation
des faits qui découle de la gestion du
pays aussi bien par la droite que par la
gauche et singulièrement depuis douze
ans par la gauche qui rendent les
français triste qu'elle sait c'est
l'absence de solution que propose
justement les partis de l'établissement
qui acculent les français à cette
situation de morosité et de désespoir
mais monsieur tapie et représentant il a
été ministre socialiste il a été dépêché
sur scène et faire de la réalité députés
socialistes il a donc il prend donc en
compte complète la politique de ceux qui
ont gouverné le pays depuis 12 ans alors
pourquoi vous et vous amis dont il parle
faits ce qui aurait été nécessaire pour
rendre les français sur bien heureux et
et par l'autre fait si
la vérité ils sont malheureuses dans les
fêtes alors moi je vous propose que pour
une fois on parle des fêtes quels sont
les fêtes qui doivent leur permettre
dans un moment de crise la crise a
existé on peut pas faire abstraction de
ça non elles existent elles continuent
elles à exister elle continue quels sont
les fêtes quels sont ceux qui doivent
pouvoir vous permettre de dire la france
est dans un état de maladie très avancée
qui frôle la mort c'est ça que j'ai
besoin de savoir parce que moi je
retrouve pas ça alors je retrouve des
millions de gens qui souffrent non mais
c'est pas le problème de ces souffrances
toujours connu les moments où il y avait
des gens qui souffraient il n'était pas
en train de se bourrer est de cachets
pour dormir il avait paru dans des
caches et
ça n'est pas moi qui empoisonnent leur
la france par un certain nombre
d'articles autres on va on va être très
concret les uns et les autres
les français qui vous écoutent risque
pas de s'endormir ce soir une pas besoin
de cash est donc vous fait le même
constat ya une crise oui mais rien dire
pourquoi il ya une crise
mais d'accord mais les téléspectateurs
mais je dois venir l'arrêter mais vous
allez parler vous allez parler on a un
décompte précis ne vous inquiétez pas
vous avez votre temps de parole vous
fait le même constat il ya une
augmentation du chômage mais je veux
savoir comment le front national et
comment le mrg comment jean marie le pen
et comment bernard tapie peuvent ou
veulent lutter contre le chômage ce
qu'elle soit n'en attendait d'abord
quels sont les dangers principaux qui
menace le pays qui le menacent gravement
qui sont déjà largement en cours c'est
en effet le chômage de non pas trois
millions trois cent mille personnes mais
de près de 6 millions si on ajoute ceux
qui dépendent du traitement social du
chômage les pré retraités etc
ministre mais il y à l'immigration il
est entré en france plus de 10 millions
d'étrangers en 30 ans c'est l'aveu du
gouvernement il y à l'insécurité qui en
découlent et qui transforment certaines
de nos villes en véritable bombe pour
l'avenir il y a le poids écrasant des
impôts et des charges sociales qui
interdit toute reprise et tout
redémarrage de l'activité il y à de
terribles dangers du sida il y a
l'extension de la drogue c'est donc un
pays qui les frappe et et moi aussi je
rencontre des milliers des milliers de
gens et qui me font honte un parent de
leur misère de leurs malheurs de leur
tristesse et de leur désespoir mais cela
me dise al'inverse de monsieur tapie ils
me disent jean marie jean marie le pen
vivement que vous arriviez au pouvoir
alors changer tout cela puisque les gens
qui étaient au pouvoir depuis 20 ans on
ne prend que les dernières vingt années
ces gens là où était responsable de la
dégradation du climat du pays tient à
vous entendre c'est un cachet qu'il faut
prendre vous allez on va faire une
proposition à
comprendre pourquoi il dit ça monsieur
le pen parce qu'en fait il dit ça il
sait pourquoi
lorsque effectivement
ils éditent un bouquin pour que les
militants puissent faire bien leur
travail il a une formule c'est les
atouts du front national et vous allez
tout comprendre à partir de ce jeudi pas
que ya pas de souffrance 1 il y en a on
va en parler
mais voilà ce qu'ils éditent les
problèmes demeurent
or c'est parce qu'ils existent ces
grands problèmes le chômage la
délinquance que le front national a
émergé tant qu'ils ne seront pas résolus
le front national se développera et puis
plus ils s'aggraveront plus notre
mouvement prendra de l'extension mais
évidemment faire plus c'est la merde ils
ont des comptes en banque s'est par
ailleurs jean cousineau tournée glow et
landre est ce qu'un médecin et
contaminer jusqu'à fin décembre est ce
qu'un médecin et contre la maladie avec
un évident qu'il ya une épidémie de
bronze ou le médecin travaille beaucoup
explique pourquoi un problème déjà grave
on en fait un problème encore plus grave
vous avez par exemple donné and c'est le
temps que je passe sur les écrans du nid
qui permet qui permet certainement pas
ce soir vous êtes
tous les cinq ans on pardonne attendait
non on va prendre au thème par thème
commencer par le chômage on a déjà parlé
dans le chômage et par exemple de
l'immigration alors vous avez 10 6
millions de chômeurs je prends le
chiffre officiel sur lequel tout le
monde s'entend 3 millions 3 mais on va
pas discuter du chiffre comment faites
vous concrètement pour donner du travail
aux plus de 3 millions alors vraiment là
il ne peut pas y avoir on ne peut pas y
avoir de traitement
102 therapeutics ans un diagnostic exact
et les gouvernements jusqu'à présent de
gauche comme de droite ont le seuil de
l'établissement honte fait une erreur
capitale sur cette analyse
volontairement ou involontairement les
causes principales du chômage sont
d'abord le poids excessif en france le
monde des charges sociales et et des
impôts alors c'est que deuxièmement on
voit là j'entends déçu quand vous dites
est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour une
baisse des charges sociales absolument
et des impôts c'est indispensable 1.0 et
des non bien sûr que non c'est absurde
mais une baisse des impôts une réforme
fiscale fondamental qu'ils fassent
reposer plus d'ailleurs le l'impôt sur
le capital que sur le travail alors que
le gouvernement socialiste dans lequel a
siégé monsieur tapie a pris la position
exactement inverse mais il laissez moi
dire quelles sont les causes de ces
étudiants mais bien sûr que si ça sert à
rien vous avez déjà c'est pas vous qui
paraît sur la notion nous a justement il
faut faire d'abord un diagnostic dressé
mois suivants premièrement
la migration vers l'avenir et il y à
l'ouverture et même la suppression des
frontières car on constate précisément
que il ya une coïncidence absolue entre
le moment où le chômage commence à
augmenter et la progression plus
exactement là le l'abaissement des
frontières en europe dans le traité de
rome et depuis l'acte unique et de queen
fait voir maintenant alors sur les
migrations j'entendrai votre décision ou
la mesure que vous préconisez restons
sur le chômage je veux pas bon alors le
chômage ne vais pas vous dire est ce que
les images illégales pour cela deux en
gros en gros sur le plan de l'europe le
chômage peut pas évidemment être réglée
intégralement mais en tout cas au niveau
de l'europe ya des moyens développés des
grands travaux de communication sur les
hôpitaux sur les crèches sur les
autoroutes sur les transports sur les
chemins de fer il ya beaucoup de besoins
de chacun le sent bien par conséquent
leur répétant mesure de créer
ponctuellement des emplois sur des
investissements lourds que chaque état
de la communauté européenne peut pas
faire ce plan national les français en
ont assez qu'on leur explique la méthode
qu'il faudrait utiliser pour le régler
ou les raisons pour lesquelles il y en a
alors je vais vous dire moi y en a trois
je vais proposer je veux savoir ce que
font national passe là dessus le premier
c'est sur les jeunes et la lah sur les
jeunes le chômage et pas seulement du
chômage car il est grave pour tout le
monde les jeunes les moins jeunes femmes
ou hommes les jeunes il a un drame
supplémentaire d'abord il est le seul
pays la france où il ya 20% de sa
jeunesse qui est exclu du travail ça
c'est le seul pays donc c'est pas
européen puisque les autres que l'on 6,6
deuxième sujet mais moins qu'en france 5
% et 6 % moins qu'en france deuxième
sujet c'est que en fait nos structures
sociologique oms les apprends soit
l'école soit dans sa famille soit dans
son boulot
lorsqu'un jeune les trois ou quatre
premières années de sa vraie vie ou
délibérée de l'école et de la tutelle ou
de l'armée ou de sa famille s'y connaît
pas le travail pour se structurer
simplement pour avoir une idée de ce
seuil ça c'est de la sociologie la
relation c'est bien c'est que les autres
et c est ce qui se passe il se passe
qu'à ce moment là il revient plus dans
notre société il se fait la sienne et il
est totalement déconnectée de l'année
alors cette jeunesse qu'est ce qui se
passe lorsque notre patrie est en danger
lorsque la patrie est en danger parce
que un ennemi éventuel va l'attaquer
c'est son devoir elle met le casque
lourd elle met un fusil sur l'épaule un
uniforme et elle va donner sa vie pour
sauver sa patrie c'est son rôle c'est
son devoir l'acceptent là aujourd'hui
cette jeunesse elle est en danger elle
est en danger de mort le reste de la
patrie doit avoir le sens du sacrifice
qu'est là quand c'est la guerre qu'on
doit impérativement impérativement au
moins sur les trois premières années de
leur existence professionnelle leur
donner un emploi obligatoire et on peut
le faire il ya 750 mille jeunes comme ça
alors ça coûte combien soixante cinq
milliards c'est-à-dire un tiers de ce
qui est dépensé en sottise par défaut
stage par des formations bidons qui
débouche sur rien par le 1% patronal qui
pour l'instant sert à quelques cadres
pourra prendre des cours de russe ou des
cours exotiques je dis qu'aujourd'hui le
devoir impératif
ces deux mètres au moins 600 1000 bosses
au boulot deuxième lane assist et ça
c'est des maraudes et moi je vais
laisser des séquelles mais j'ai la
deuxième mesure sur saignement avec le
trc du langage et s'étaler sur ses
limites je veux finir les deux mesures à
lire et vous parlerez vous expliquerez
les causes le comment du pourquoi mais
je veux donner les mesures concrètes
vite voilà deuxième mesure concrète plus
de la moitié des gens femmes et hommes
de plus de 50 ans sont prêts à accepter
de travail à mi-temps pour 80% de leur
salaire
80% de leur salaire deux fois ça fait
cent soixante pour 60% du salaire vous
libérer 300 mille emplois en quelques
mois et enfin en dehors des vrais
métiers pour lesquels on verra ce qu'on
peut faire vous avez actuellement des
gens qu'on de boulot alors celui qui a
dix neuf onze mille francs par mois de
retraite je comprends qu'il puisse faire
un deuxième petit boulot mais
actuellement il ya plus de quatre cent
mille personnes qu'on deux emplois et
parmi eux des gens qu'on 20 25 mille
trente mille francs de retraite je
trouve qu'actuellement on n'a pas le
droit d'avoir deux emplois lorsqu'il ya
autant de gens qui sont sans emploi
voilà trois mesures qui font six cent
mille 2 300 milles et peut-être 150
milles lorsque le chômage bascule d'un
coût à un million un million et demi de
moins tous les économistes vous diront
ça crée une émulation sacré de la
demande sacré de l'embauchent ça veut
dire que ça change la structure de
l'emploi et de la demande voilà les
mesures feraient alors après on peut
parler de la réduction de travail on
peut parler de carthage pour
les spectateurs auront sûrement reconnu
là le langage électorale habituelle de
ceux qui étaient responsables de
gouvernements n'ont manqué le ministre
socialiste et le ministre socialiste qui
étaient là qui est solidaire du
gouvernement de monsieur bérégovoy
aurait dû dire cela monsieur bérigaud
loi parce que c'est sous le gouvernement
socialiste que le nombre des chômeurs a
doublé alors et c'est à la suite de la
politique socialiste pendant 12 ans
évidemment c'est le gouvernement vous
nous dites ce que vous allez faire
demain mais vous ne dites pas ce que
vous avez fait hier lise la mort c'est
un an mais vous aimez vous êtes
solidaires des sérieux bien passé ce
sont les gouvernements socialistes qui
sont responsables en 12 ans du w pas de
solution sur la part des agissements du
doublement du nombre des chômeurs qui a
des choses le mot rapide a été
doublement du nombre des chômeurs le
doublement du nombre des criminels et
les délinquants
enfin j'en passe le doublement du nombre
des immigrés ce sont toutes ces raisons
là sur lesquels les amis politiques de
monsieur tapie aurait pu agir puisqu'il
était le gouvernement ils n'ont pas agi
et justement la progression hélas vers
le bas c'est fait alors comme tout le
monde il ya dire vous savez oui comme ça
mais parlons pas de passé regardons vers
l'avenir je vous garde et on vers
l'avenir nous allons dire ce que nous
adopterons de cette souhaitait toujours
à qu'on n'est pas une mesure pourquoi
n'aurait elle pas un chien dans une
bonne gestion pour les vautours à la
baisse
pourquoi la société
pourquoi mais oui c'est vous qui dites
c'est pourquoi les socialistes pourquoi
les soldats l'italie fait pourquoi l'art
15 étiez ministre suis fière d'avoir été
si vous êtes fier accepter la
responsabilité l'accès alors les
socialistes gouvernent depuis 12 ans
pourquoi n'ont ils pas fait quand il
était au pouvoir pourquoi n'ont ils pas
pris les mesures que monsieur tapie
propose aujourd'hui il a brusquement
découvert probablement que je vais pas
tout vous avez découvert la vérité
peut-être en lisant mais rien n'est
sûrement pas s'engager chez vous je vois
rien qui créent l'emploi vous expliquez
vous expliquer tout ce qu'il est coutume
c'est fini ça veut dire y compris
d'ailleurs dans leur propre vous n'avez
pas créé d'emplois vous avez supprimé
alors j'ai fait plus de dix mille
diderot jeune chômeur ce combat serait
et comment c'est pas comme ça que c'est
bon ça va pas ça parce que c'est chaud
sommes tous responsables de nos actes
vous venez de la cgt sur murray mais 2,2
société civile vous avez une expérience
jeune homme d'affaires commençait pas et
adra contre des hommes et non mais parce
que sinon on va partir ce site dans tous
les niveaux mais c'est quelqu'un que
veut dire votre ménage comme je suis
prêt à aller où vous voulez moi ça les i
mais je vous parle baissier scénario
boomer tout quoi c'est dans votre
bouquin eux mêmes vous dites n'importe
quoi je vous laisserai pas dire alors on
s'arrêtera s'il le faut mais je vous
laisserai pas mois à venir n'importe
quoi mais je vous entends life a fait
les journalistes vous le laisse dire
qu'ils vous le dire parce qu'ils n'ont
pas le courage parce qu'on fait que
c'est vous qui étoit jurançon se dire
nous les jours voulait terminer rule et
de seul personnel vous n'allez pas
capable de mission à l'écran tous les
jours et tous les soirs vous n'êtes pas
capable de créer non bernard maingain
est venue une sérieuse c'est moi qui
réponds là puisque l écran vous avez dit
journaliste qui laisse dire n'importe
quoi moi je reste pas dire n'importe
quoi jean marie le pen dont je vous
laisse pas dire non plus n'importe quoi
quant à bernard henri lévy devenue une
seule fois une soleil aura 3 minutes la
jeune fille et la terreur dont monsieur
mais il
n'ya pas que votre antenne bon et bien
évidemment alors on ses deux chiens ont
mené l'économie les salahi la voiture
j'aimais le département une tous les
deux mais c'est ça parce que c'est nous
qui payons quand même j'ai monté les
vannes aux français qu'ils aient mon
travail pour vous et pour l'heure
d'accord je suis pas chez vous ne mettez
pas je suis à rallier deux alors
continuer de débattre sur le chômage
vous étiez en train de parler des
mesures oui justement mais il n'est pas
possible d'y insérer en hiver manens il
utilise sa technique il a l'habitude
d'être seul à parler moi je voudrais
dire des raisons d'abord la faille
récifal ce sont les gouvernants des 20
dernières années dont les socialistes
pendant dix ans qui sont responsables de
la situation actuelle du pays pourquoi
n'ont ils pas fait passer était au
pouvoir ce que monsieur tapie propose
aujourd'hui il avait suffisamment
d'influencé sur monsieur bérégovoy pour
le faire adopter pour lui faire adopter
ces méthodes là il ne l'a pas fait alors
il vient nous dire aujourd'hui en
campagne électorale comme il l'a souvent
fait pendant les campagnes électorales
faire des promesses dont tout le monde
sait qu'ils ne les a jamais été dit mais
vous faites un numéro vous parler pour
faire des mobs et à la fin des bourgs
est rien les gens qui vont vous écoutez
là qui sont membres du front national
qui sont sympathisants à la fin ils vont
dire il a beaucoup qu'est-ce qui nous a
dit aux fins et mes fans et j'ai patiné
lundi un truc on est sur le sujet ou
baisser les charges on ne sait en
général en est attendu mardi pour son de
la france mais vous ne laissez pas
parler alors quelle mesure d'inverser le
courant de l'immigration parallèle
évident que chaque fois qu'un émigré en
toi là il prend le travail vins français
l'art premier temps 34
le gouvernement socialiste avait d une
mesure tout à fait louable qui était
celle de la préférence nationale n'est
ce pas et il a appelé les socialistes
l'ont abrogée en 81 il faut donc
évidemment diminuer le nombre des
immigrés car quand il ne travaille pas
c'est encore pire puisque avec leur
famille avec leurs femmes leurs enfants
leurs parents ils sont aux crochets de
la société vasselle répondent maintenant
on attendait le chez moi finir vous êtes
un étudiant la tentation est ce que nous
aimerions avoir
non mais je les élève
en matière ça se met sans cesse
interrompu alors moi je peux faire ça
aussi ne rentre pas défis
à relever les frontières il faut
rétablir des contrôles parce que si on
ne rétablit pas c'est contrôler
l'ensemble l'ensemble des sociétés
françaises de l'économie disparaîtra il
ne supportera pas la concurrence et par
la délocalisation d'ailleurs monsieur
vous vous avez vous même délocalisé je
n'ai pas voulu faire de même
pour une de vos entreprises ont moins
alors donc immigration la frontière tant
elle est votre avis alors d'abord quand
on parle de l'immigration il faut que
j'en parle quand même de trois minutes
si vous le voulez bien on a parlé de
premier de rémunération comme étant
responsable c'est là où nos sociétés
sont totalement différentes en dehors
des joutes verbales il ya un fond je
parle pas du problème moral je vais en
parler quand même un peu après pour leur
faire plaisir à ces immigrés d'abord les
chiffres à chaque fois c'est n'importe
quoi il ya trois millions et demi
exactement d'étrangers dont un million
et demi qui sont de la communauté il
reste donc environ 1000 basque ils tous
les ans de nationalité française ou
autre chose et pour commencer par un tir
laissez moi parler il reste 2 millions
sans y en a 400 milles qui sont
demandeurs d'emploi le reste qui
travaillent ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui
d'une manière absolument certaine et je
veux que les gens sachent c'est quand on
fait la balance de ce que coûte ces
immigrés de ce qu'ils rapportent je
parle à l'état sur les prestations
sociales ils ne sont pas en déficit il
rapporte largement autant que ce qu'il
coûte largement autant tout le monde le
sait sauf les gens du front national et
j'entends ça à marseille sans arrêt
qu'est ce qui nous coûte la famille
nombreuse ce qui coûte est moins
important que ce qu'il rapporte
deuxièmement plus de la moitié des
médias qui font plus de la moitié des
métiers qu'ils font nous ne le ferions
pas
troisièmement ya un million de français
qui travaillent à l'étranger si demain
on commence à jouer le coup du la france
aux français et la préférence nationale
nous on embauche que les français va se
passer trois choses la première c'est
joue signale que si tous ces émigrés
s'en vont c'est la faillite économique
parce que ce sont des consommateurs sont
pas seulement des producteurs y consomme
ce qu'ils produisent qu'en général ils
consomment plutôt dans les prestations
donc a besoin les services d'autobus
service du métro tout ça ce sont des
consommateurs qui consomme donc un
déficit colossal
deuxièmement vous croyez que les autres
vont nous laisser faire vous croyez dans
la communauté mondiale on va dire vous
vous refusez les étrangers et les
étrangers qui travaillent en france on
va les accepter ça veut dire qu'il faut
faire revenir donc il est clair que ce
problème qui consiste encore une fois a
désigné comme ça comme on le fait tout
le temps des gens sous prétexte qu'ils
sont des immigrés comme les responsables
du chômage alors si c'est les
socialistes sont les visuels ils ont
même récemment sa moye canton mervans
parler après si vous voulez son associé
la façon de gérer leur situation en
france puis à quelque chose moi qui me
fait de la peine si vous les voyez vous
montrer quelque chose là on va bientôt
fêter le débarquement moi je voulais
montrer cette photo audrey cette photo
là hein c'est la reconquête de la france
cathy son parti de corse et qui sont
montés jusqu'à paris c'était sur les
champs-elysées c'était l'esprit 1 vous
connaissez ça vous vous le connaissez
les avaries céder les tirailleurs
marocains s'étaient les sénégalais alors
voilà de maintenant ce qu'on en fait ces
gens là on en fait des dessins sur le
plein et distribue des dessins avec
attention à vous l'immigration c'est des
dragons qui jette le feu qui sont en
train de manger les petits français
willy lisation s'assèche à seulement et
pas les immigrés c'est simplement
l'immigration rang récurrent parce que
la nature de la france c'est justement
le contraire nhtsa elle doit être
capable l'allemagne a intégré 20
millions d'allemands de l'est et je vous
assure bien que les allemands de l'est
après le passage de plusieurs dizaines
d'années chez les communistes ils
étaient largement si différents des
allemands que les algériens sûr que donc
les chats d'avancé car il était français
ils étaient encore français que les
allemands n'étaient plus dans
l'allemagne de l'ouest oui m'enfin ça
veut donc dire que cette immigration
elle comme ça des problèmes énormes bon
on va en parler tout seul mais
certainement pas sur l'influencé on ne
va pas se convainquent ce qui est
important c'est parce que c'est que les
électeurs français les électrices sache
ce que nous avons comme programme
monsieur tapie a comme programme libre
entrée des étrangers en france et
simplification mais pression normale
mais comment allez-vous le contrôler
puisque vous êtes pour le chat - un jour
pour la suppression des frontières pas
moi le seul et donc moi je suis pour le
rétablissement des fonds qui est moi
aussi z pour l'europe de maastricht et
l'europe de maastricht jamais fait c'est
la suppression totale des frontières il
faut vous êtes pour le vote des immigrés
c'est ceci que les électeurs doivent
retenir de la 100 milles moi je dis je
dis que il est nécessaire pour
sauvegarder la sécurité de la france sa
liberté et sa prospérité de dégonfler le
nombre des immigrés dans notre pays de
faire une politique d'immigration
inverse de celle qui a été menée depuis
vingt ans et qui a abouti à cames les
notre pays sous le poids qui a été
vérifié nous avons fait des études qui
n'ont jamais été contredite
l'immigration coûte à la france 250
milliards aux parents fous voilà je
voudrais dire là dessus parce que c'est
un sujet très important c'est un sujet
très important parce qu'il ya un point
sur lequel je suis d'accord c'est
lorsqu'on a lorsqu'on a en france des
gens qui souffrent le martyr parce
qu'ils croient encore que la france est
un pays qui va les accueillir qui va
léser mais qui va leur donner ce qu'ils
pensaient pouvoir mais cognaçais vont
nous le faire merlan doit pas aimer les
jeux l'on dit déjà je ne les dit pas le
monde entier vous vouliez qui reste
français il n'ya pas longtemps encore
donc c'est pas tout à fait le monde
entier le maghreb l'afrique du nord
c'était un peu chez nous oui nous avons
en entier ce n'est pas de ma faute alors
par conséquent je dis pas qu'on est en
mesure aujourd'hui bien sûr il y en a
même en france que j'aimerais bien
pouvoir aider à retourner dans leur pays
parce qu'ils sont plus malheureux en
france qui seraient dans leur pays donc
le problème n'est pas là mais lorsqu'un
immigré est en situation régulière
lorsque cet étranger à donner son temps
à donner son travail a donné son devoir
il est normal qui revendique ses droits
et nous devons les lui assume et on en a
les moyens bien sûr qu'il ya des grands
chantiers à travailler on peut pas
laisser 90 % d'une population étrangère
dans une cité dans lequel il ya plus que
la mort de la drogue la délinquance mais
quand vous prenez 10 familles de ces
immigrés dans des blocs de 100
appartements les laisse 90 sont
satisfaits et les dix aussi simplement
peut pas les laisser concentré dans une
misère incroyable c'est un devoir qu'on
a on a les moyens de faire ne dit pas
par où les envoyés ne dit pas par contre
mais y'a des constructions actuelles qui
sont en chantier sur des logements
sociaux il faut réserver 10% de ces
logements sociaux s à ces gens là est ce
que vous êtes d'accord pour que s'il ya
une guerre civile en algérie des
centaines de milliers de fait les gars
de flm sûr qu'on vienne en france bien
sûr que nous et vous avez pourtant dit
que bien sûr dès qu'on met en oeuvre les
jets d'asile et qu'ils arrivent quand
vous avez entendu salon qu'est ce que
vous voulez faire s'ils viennent mais je
vais faire exactement ce qu'il faudrait
faire aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'il ne
vienne pris avec est-ce que vous avez
alors il ya deux trois choses à faire la
première c'est que la communauté
européenne elle a le devoir de créer sur
le grand maghreb des structures
d'accueil pour ceux qui seront pas
contents de rester en algérie si le fils
sévices et bien d'autres choses qu'il
faut faire monsieur c'est ce que
bourguiba lui pour mme indépendants sont
donnant à la femme se lavent la vraie
place qui lui qui lui revient allez dire
ça à alger n'ont pas la place des
parents feront pas la ménagère derrière
ses casseroles persévérance et hal gill
venu deuxième faire ces
quatre mois je veux faire mais moi je
femmes qui le souhaitent d'élever leurs
enfants chaînes qui le souhaitent oui
oui et d'être aidés par la communauté
car elle libère avait agi de travail si
vous voulez pour être simple sur ce
problème qui risque d'arriver qui
risquerait il faut tout faire pour
éviter qu'ils arrivent mais c'est
certainement pas en leur donnant
l'impression l'illusion en tout cas la
promesse qu'on va les accueillir que je
veux régler le problème je me sens pas
capable de ça la lumière monsieur le pen
la frontière de la frontière de l'europe
je la veux autant que vous vous savez ce
que madrid uru pire mais vous savez très
bien qu'elle ne saura jamais les
rassurer regardez bien sûr que les
commet mais évidemment schengen par
exemple des monts les videurs non
l'italie demandent maintenant donc dans
l'accord de schengen que les gens
d'afrique du nord soit obligé de voir un
visa pour entrer l'italie ce qui n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui donc il faut pas
dire aux gens que l'europe ça consiste à
ouvrir les frontières faire rentrer en
masse le ciel c'est le principe de la
série fao c'est à part le grasse la
mienne vous allez voir réussir un
supplément du tout baser là dessus les
arbres morts comment justement les
frontières vous pouvez pas les maîtres
d'une manière légale obligatoire monte
infranchissable dès lors qu'il ya trop
de différences entre ce qu'ils ont et
ceux qui ont parlé de l'homme ne veut
pas mourir il sait tout ce qui se passe
sur la planète en constant vous croyez
qu'il accepterait de mourir de faim
pendant qu'à 1000 kilomètres de là y en
a il y en a qui se sucrent autant
alors vous faites des bunkers vous vivez
vous fait vivre les gens dans des
coffre-fort avant l'année l'autre il
nous reste une vingtaine de minutes pour
ce débat sachez qu'une équipe on va
parler de le rappeler sachez qu'une
équipe se trouve en régie et tient les
comptes un des temps de parole dont vous
avez bernard tapie une minute trente
d'avancé vous écouter parlons un peu
juste quelques mots sur l'algérie
il faut pas oublier que c'est le
gouvernement français le gouvernement de
monsieur françois mitterrand qui en
matière internationale à le domaine
réservé que l'on sait qu'il a d'ailleurs
hérité du général de gaulle et qu'il a
conservée et dont on sait qu'il est le
procès le premier protecteur de monsieur
bernard tapie c'est lui qui a approuvé
l'interruption du processus démocratique
qui avaient été entamées en algérie
entre les deux tours on a arrêté les
élections est il un mystère pour
personne que cela a été fait pour
empêcher la défaite électorale du fln
car comme dans beaucoup d'endroits nous
avons choisi et comme toujours nous
avons d'ailleurs choisi celui qui allait
perdre celui qui avait le pouvoir en est
membre a donné comme nous avons soutenu
le gouvernement hutu au rwanda n'est ce
pas et que nous abritons chez nous
aujourd'hui ce gouvernement qui est
responsable des massacres qui ont été
déclenchées et bien là encore nous
retombons sur les responsabilités du
gouvernement socialo sur les contours de
l'europe on a bien compris en vous
écoutant l'un et l'autre que vous êtes
aux antipodes l'un de l'autre free sur
cette europe après tout on va parler un
mot de l'europe puisque les français
vont
lire le 12 juin l'un et l'autre
vous vous dites l'europe fédérale c'est
quoi leur finalement je suis le dernier
par rapport aux pères fondateurs de
l'europe je suis le dernier à vouloir
dire à oser dire on peut reconnaître ça
que je suis pour l'europe fédérale
parier que ça il faut appeler longtemps
il faut appeler un chat un chat baudis
nous dit je veux une autre europe et une
demande à 30% des électeurs français de
voter dans une robe foncée pas ce que
c'est car il y c'est une europe
autrement et même michel il dit pas
c'est ça va c'est au car il dit parce
que ça va être il dit ça sera autre
chose on l'a trouvé un statut refaire
quelque chose comme ça pour moi
j'appelle ça une europe fédérale
pourquoi parce qu'à des grands sujets
dans le monde que la france l'allemagne
l'angleterre l'italie peuvent pas régler
à leur niveau la france un grand pays
qui fait qu'un pur sang de la planète et
les grands fléaux de ce monde lorsqu'on
rentre dans le troisième millénaire avec
d'un côté l'amérique qui est en train
qui est en train de se faire un seul
continent politiquement d'accord le
mexique est en train de réunir les deux
quand on voit ce qui se passe avec le
japon la chine le sud est asiatique moi
j'ai peur de me retrouver entre ces deux
blocs là la petite france même
courageuse j'ai donc besoin sur des
sujets essentiels que sont la monnaie
unique
mille milliards de dollars circulent par
jour dans le monde je suis ou moins la
france la défense de l'environnement des
centaines de centrales nucléaires en
urss anciennes sont en train de nous
nous risquer de nous péter dans la
figure c'est moi la france qui va les
contrôles et les maintenir ou
éventuellement les arrêter
la relation sociale on est obligé
d'aplanir la relation là je suis
d'accord sinon au bout d'un moment s'il
y en a qui sont prêts à travailler pour
200 francs par mois et l'autre pour 9000
je peux pas y arriver et enfin quatrième
fait pas trop regardé l'émission pour
toute à l'heure parce que c'est vrai
s'accentue je voudrais souligner a donné
ces points là y'a que l'europe fait de
leur vie veulent faire face m envie en
contrepartie va je vais vite en contre
partie de ça parce qu'elle a le pouvoir
de s'occuper de ses problèmes que les
nations ne peuvent pas elle ne s'occupe
de rien d'autre c'est clair que c'est au
contraire plus grande liberté des pâtes
riz pour prendre en charge leurs
problèmes spécifiques
je voudrais souligner combien l'histoire
récente a montré la fausseté du
raisonnement selon lequel les grands
empires étaient les plus performants
économiquement dans les 50 dernières
années ce ne sont ni l'urss
ni les états unis qui ont été les
puissances économiques les plus
performantes mais deux nations moyennes
le japon et l'allemagne et par
conséquent ceci contredit tout à fait
avant tout à fait le raisonnement c'est
le ceux qui souhaitent que nous
devenions des états unis d'europe c'est
ce que vous souhaitez dans le fond et
que nous les vernir les états unis dans
le fond mais ceux-ci postule que la
france disparaît pas il n'y aura plus
d'armée française il n'y aura plus de
monnaie française il n'y aura plus
d'autorité et de souveraineté française
et ceci est contraire à la fois aux lois
de la république à la constitution est
évidemment à l'intérêt vital de la
france et des français jean marie le pen
est ce que vous êtes prêts à mourir pour
sarajevo non honnêtement non
déjà je crois qu'on peut demander aux
citoyens français d'être prêts à mourir
pour son pays
demandez de mourir pour d'autres raisons
ceci est un problème d'un engagement
personnel moi j'admire est monsieur
bernard henri lévy par exemple pour ne
parler que de lui si il mettait ses
idées en accord ses actes en accord avec
ses idées et s'il s'engageait dans
l'armée bosniaque que je n'y verrais pas
personnellement d'inconvénients encore
je ne sois pas sûr que notre législation
militaire le permettent mais je pense
que là encore nous avons voulu nous
mêler d'affaires qui ne nous regardait
que de loin et nous avons l'europe c'est
peut-être une affaire européenne dans le
dans l'application des principes de
l'onu l'onu préconise ce qu'on n'a
jamais respecté ni dans le golfe
persique ni nulle part ailleurs
préconise que ce soit les conflits
soient réglés autant que possible sur le
plan régional se devait donc être à
l'europe de le régler elle a démontré la
son impuissance alors qu'elle existe
économiquement et on peut dire tout de
même dans les relations diplomatiques
relativement étroite et bien et n'a été
impuissante et nous sommes allés là
essayé de séparer des intérêts qu'ils
n'étaient pas les nôtres résultat nous
serons hays et nos soldats sont pris en
otage c'est pour ça que je demande que
le contingent français soit relevé je
note que monsieur président de la
république a appelé les américains et
les russes à venir s'intéresser à une
affaire européenne s'était l'aveu de
l'impuissance totale de l'europe à
régler ces problèmes là il ya équilibre
des temps de parole vous êtes prêts à
mourir pour sarajevo même un tapis mais
je suis prêt comme chaque français à
mourir pour chaque cause qui lorsque
vous êtes en face du problème ne peut
pas ne pas vous interpeller il ya deux
cent cinquante mille nord en trois ans
ça fait cinq siècles que ça dure on est
à tergiverser un coup certains proposent
d'augmenter les phénomènes qui
risquerait d'amener à la paix d'autres
sont un peu plus courageux pour faire la
guerre puisqu'ils disent il faut
absolument donner à ces pauvres
bosniaque c'est vrai qu'ils sont en
train de se faire tuer sans pouvoir se
défendre
donc c'est la lever l'embargo faudrait
beaucoup de temps pour voir définir ça
nous on a une proposition à faire à
l'eiti médias tel est possible c'est de
l'intérêt dans le rôle c'est de
l'intégrer dans la commune europe encore
plus grande non mais celle là là
l'ancienne yougoslavie avait fait la
demande oui bon il ya quatre millions
d'âmes intégré ça coûterait un écu par
européen par an pour les amener à notre
niveau ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'on
cesse de tergiverser de croire au père
noël que l'appel va durer car là bas si
vous faites la paix il faut à 25 ans de
nouveau des casques bleus pour qu'elle
reste il ya quelque chose que je peux
pas laisser tout ça parce que ont même
la france autant que monsieur le pen
ceux qui sont projetés laisser croire
qu'on est en train de gérer les émois
finir quand laissez moi finir qu'on est
en train de dire que l'europe va
complètement faire éliminer la france
que l'europe c'est la fin de notre
souveraineté nationale si c'est la fin
de mai ces deux contraire s'arrête la
fin vous savez toutes les plus grandes
civilisations même les plus puissantes
quand elles ont commencé à se refermer
sur elle-même elles sont mortes elles
ont disparu la france elle est capable
simplement on n'a pas la trouille nous
les français de notes france ils ont pas
peur de la concurrence ils ont peur de
personne ce qu'ils savent par contre
c'est que l'union fait la force
lorsqu'on est dans une situation où
notre unité mesure de taille permet plus
de faire face au problème moi j'aimerais
mieux je vous l'avouer sur le pen
j'aimerais mieux pas vrai besoin oui je
voulais vous franchement si je pouvais
être sûr que la france soit capable de
relever le défi face au monde tout seul
je préférais qui le drapeau français ne
peut pas le faire je vous garantis que
de pays européens qui ont largement
préserver leur autonomie et leur
prospérité sans faire partie de l'europe
lequel puisque par exemple autriche par
exemple les pays scandinaves qui ont
tout à fait la france elle est belle
elle est la seule à bénéficier vraiment
de l'europe vous savez quand vous dites
confiantes et nous perdons 20 milliards
mais celles fournies mais je rappelle
export buzz beaucoup plus pour n'importe
mais que tesla gras fois j'entends m sur
le pen parle et vous vous souvenez dont
c'était votre adjoint qui rencontrait à
mes amis mes amis et qui visait les
agriculteurs les pêcheurs et céline
martinez ray les agriculteurs ils ont du
compte ça comme une insulte il était en
train de les plaindre en compte en train
de les désigner comme des victimes c'est
nos héros nationaux ils ont fait de
l'agriculture la deuxième du monde mais
vous savez tout de même 3 millions
d'agriculteurs siège à ceux de leurs
terres la vingt deuxième du monde c'est
à dire qu ils sont excédentaires de 60
milliards alors ils ont des problèmes
mais au contact pour les féliciter faut
pas dire regardez leur propre culture
vous avez un jour déchets en les
négociant a vu les pêcheurs eux aussi en
matière agricole et pêcheurs ils sont
rodés me dois prendre ils sont en train
de souffrir à cause de quoi à cause de
la concurrence internationale s'il avait
su c'est maintenant non ça messieurs que
si ton chéri la projection pêcheurs et
regardez bien c'est pas ça c'est la
dévaluation de la livre et de la peut
être que commencer à les mettre dans une
situation insupportable
oui mais c'est ça le début avant suivent
ensuite l'europe avait prévu de
contingenter sur le poisson blanc sa
patte et flan france l'europe avait
prévu des contrôles d'hygiène s'apprête
effet en france soit parce que les
américains les ont fusé baddou mediact
l'europe alors est sauvé mais chalon et
nous avons plié parce que dans les dates
dans l'europe ce qu'on ne leur parle
d'un pêcheur ce que le vois pas jouer au
meilleur c'est que leurs habits c'est
bien l'europe fédérale que souhaite
monsieur tapie elle l etat âme finalité
mondialisme visant à s'étendre et ceci
sous le contrôle bien évidemment de la
seule puissance qui anime ce courant ce
sont les états unis d'amérique ont amené
moi je considère les états unis
d'amérique comme un allié je ne les
considère pas du tout comme un maître
allez on a bien compris vos divergences
sur l'europe les soldats allemands de
leur corps sur les champs elysées le 14
juillet votre avis mais jean marie le
pen écoutez
je serai david de ménager dans ce
domaine là les sensibilités autant je
pense qu à une autre date il aurait été
possible de faire défiler des
contingences européen à paris choisir la
fête nationale me paraît comporter des
arrière-pensées il y à des
arrière-pensées justement européiste
pour montrer que ce n'est désormais plus
l'armée française qui défilent le jour
de la fête nationale c'est l'armée
européenne
et voilà pourquoi j'exprime cette
réserve en revanche je pense que les
tous les souvenirs de la guerre doivent
aujourd'hui
s'estomper pour laisser la place à la
concorde des pays des grands pâtissiers
des pays européens je crois que l'oubli
l'oubli des souffrances à un moment
donné tout même doit permettre aux
enfants ou petits enfants de ceux qui
sont combattus de se retrouver et de
coopérer ensemble dans la paix bernard a
fait vous savez ceux qui sont morts pour
la dernière guerre mondiale honte à
mener la réflexion de ceux qui ont
échappé plus jamais ça c'est comme ça
que les leurs l'idée de l'europe c'était
qu'on ne se bat plus que ce ne se mettre
plus à mort alors je crois que les pères
et mères et grands-pères et grands-mères
aujourd'hui on n'a pas tellement de lui
mieux 2 de se flatter de la france qu'on
est en train de transmettre à nos jeunes
si on reprend pas du poil de la bête et
si on n'est pas vraiment capable de
donner beaucoup d'énergie pour s'en
sortir au moins sur ce point là je crois
qu'on a bien fait les choses on ne se
bat plus on ne se battra plus il ya
pendant ces il ya peu de pays qui
peuvent se vendre et de dire on a des
chances que nos jeunes nice va mourir
pour la trop nette ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas l'europe qui a eut obtenu ce
résultat par l'otan non plus alors en
fait c'est en fait l'équilibré des
terreurs conclusion convoqués par les
deux grands pays internationaux c'est ça
le problème reparler d'un mal revient en
france juste un mal qui intéresse le
monde entier le sida vous avais parlé il
ya un instant jean marie le pen il ya un
débat à l'assemblée nationale simone
veil a par l'est les députés sont
prononcés contre le dépistage
obligatoire et simone veil elle-même
s'est prononcée contre la levée du
secret médical votre avis je crois que
les pouvoirs publics et les hommes
politiques ne loue et les femmes
politiques ne prennent pas la mesure du
danger que représente ainsi dale dans
l'avenir tout le monde c'est comme pour
les migrations tout le monde a l'air de
croire qu'il s'agit d'un sujet qui est
fixe et qu'il faut résorber le sida est
en pleine expansion et tout récemment
des spécialistes déclarait qu' en france
dans la région parisienne un français
sur vingt est atteint par le hiv et l'un
d'eux disait nous avons deux cent mille
séropositifs et peut-être demain 55
millions ça n'est pas moi c'est le
docteur rosenbaum willy rozenbaum qu'il
a déclaré dans un colloque médical tout
à fait récemment je vous rappelle
cependant que en 87 quand j'ai su créé
le scandale en disant que le sida était
une maladie pandémique mortels et
qu'elle allait se répandre sur le monde
et j'avais proposé qu'à crédit de 25
milliards soit votée nous sommes en 1994
on en est encore à des mesurettes qui
sont tout à fait hors de proportion avec
le danger représenté par le sida mais
aussi en afrique + plus que les conflits
intéresse quelques minutes en elles
mêmes avaient l'un et l'autre d'être
bref sur le sida chine en malaisie sur
le sida
je crois que l'émission d'autrefois à
monthey a montré toute l'étendue du
problème qu'on voulait pas aborder
organisée par toutes les chaînes de télé
maintenant on a abordé on a montré moi
j'ai compris il a fallu attendre minuit
pour qu'on parle des drogués ça veut
dire qu'on a fait croire aux français
que le sida c'était une maladie comme
les autres c'est une maladie qui est pas
comme là elle est la plus mortelle et
paradoxalement elle est la seule qu'on
peut ne pas attraper si on veut pas la
voir même le rhume de cerveau on n'est
pas en mesure de se garantir de ça
simplement il faut expliquer le problème
le sida n'est que la conséquence d'un
délabrement d'une jeunesse qui est
atteint par la drogue cent cinquante
mille doses qui se drogue là aussi c'est
pas des ses pains des vicieux c'est des
malades il faut traiter les drogués
comme des malades évidemment dès qu'ils
commencent à s'adonner à la au trafic et
là ça devient délinquant mais d'abord il
faut absolument s'occuper de la drogue
et des drogués cette centralisation pas
du tout je suis pour qu'un drogué
monsieur quand il est sous la dépendance
de la drogue je veux qu'ils puissent
aller dans un établissement contrôlé
maîtrisé par des médecins pour qu'ils
aillent recevoir soit le produit de
substitution soit le produit lui-même
pour que la drogue égale valeur zéro
tant que l'ags drogue sera pas vu les
papiers souffrir mardi qu'elle soit rien
de les ramener pas du tout c'est le
contraire ce qu'ils ont à me dire il
n'est pas question qu'ils aient un g qui
circulent mais il doit y avoir les
récents événements pour les trafiquants
de drogue jamais mon travail sur la
coupe et les gens deux c'est plus fort
que moi je sais pas le faire jamais
j'arriverai à me servir vous qu'on me
demandera non mais je ne peux pas si
besoin était qu'il y en a même qui vont
le voir pour être un oiseau prendre les
devants à m les jeunes par milliers que
mérite la peine de mort dont le sida la
drogue d'abord attaquez vous aux causes
quinze mille roses se suicide ça veut
dire quand même qu'on n'est pas très
très heureux sur la manière dont on les
gère vous avez bien compris que je
termine cette émission par des questions
d'actualité mais qui révèlent le climat
du pays l'arrestation et le maintien en
détention de didier pineau valencienne à
bruxelles le pdg du groupe e semaine ça
ne me choque pas
c'est malheureux pour monsieur pinault
valenciennes mais je pourrais peut-être
maîtres la vie que les gens qui se sont
portés garants de lui dans la presse le
lendemain de son arrestation j'espère
supporteront caution solidaire sur leurs
biens des condamnations qui pourrait
intervenir contre monsieur pinault
valenciennes je préfère je dois dire
comme entrepreneur je préfère monsieur
big certainement à monsieur pineau
valencienne qui lui ne m'a été un grand
créateur de chômage puisqu'il a licencié
trente mille personnes dans creusot
loire
vous êtes cette entreprise oui je suis
chef d'entreprise je pense que quand on
fait rien quand on fait pas grand chose
en tout cas où quand on fait rien on a
peu de chances de passer les excès de
vitesse ou de se faire prendre est la
justice et est très dure avec les chefs
d'entreprises à la raison de le faire on
est dans une période où la crise a fait
que certains ont pris des risques des
risques qui de temps en temps était
calculé pendant l'été pas monsieur pilon
valenciennes est pas propriétaire de
l'entreprise par conséquent on peut au
moins lui reconnaître ça c'est que s'il
a fait des actes délictueux il l'a fait
soit sans savoir qu'ils étaient des
lectures ou soit pas pour ce soir son
profit puisqu'il n'était pas
propriétaire donc il l'a fait en pensant
sûrement que c'était au profit de son
entreprise en tout cas bon je vais pas
me prononcer là dessus je veux juste
finir par donner moi parce que nous
entendu dire quelque chose monsieur sur
une radio et j'ai tout accepté mais ça
je pourrais vous dire c'est fou je dois
pas jamais dans ma vie j'écoutais un
front aux contribuables par bon
d'imposer à ces messieurs laissez moi
finir à vous avez dit un truc car c'est
pas vrai donc je vais vous le dire
lorsque j'ai pris un accord avec cette
banque c'est parce que j'avais décidé il
ya trois ans qu'on pouvait pas mélanger
les genres qui a d'un côté la politique
d'un côté littéraire et quand on fait le
bilan comme on dit il ya des actifs il
ya du tnc mais société et la corse était
simplement comme ce n'est pas le moment
idéal pareillement à l'essai mal au bout
je ne sais pas le moment idéal le
président avait trouvé une bonne mesure
qui était pas une bonne pour moi
seulement c'était on laisse un délai de
réalisation des actifs et moi j'ai fait
quelque chose qui devrait vous plaire
quand même c'est que j'avais donné
l'intégralité de mes biens personnels en
garantie si les actifs industriels
n'étaient pas suffisants alors le
changement d'attitude pourquoi je me
bats pour qu'il reste tel qu'il était
c'est parce que s'ils sont bradés dans
des conditions inacceptables
là il risque d'y avoir une insuffisance
et s'ils arrivent à tous les français
alors que l'andra mais heureusement non
mediapad insuffisances lorsque lorsqu'il
ya un milliard cent millions et paris ce
qui vous a peut-être trompé et c'est
pour ça que je vous en veux pas c'est
que vous avez lu et vous avez cru ce que
vous avez lu vous voudriez savoir vous
mieux que n'importe qui il faut se
méfier de ce décor un niveau semble
alors si vous l'acceptez il faudra se
prononcer sur ce qu'on lit regarde de
temps en temps j'ai des choses à dire
une chose c'est que je crois que la
sphère du crédit lyonnais pas seulement
la vôtre qui a manqué quelques mètres
minorité mais la sphère du crédit
lyonnais est sans doute le plus grand
scandale financier de la vème république
et il faudrait que les responsables
expliquent à autre à d'autres gens que
ceux de la commission parlementaire il
faudrait qu'ils expliquent comment on a
pu prêter des milliards à des à des
hommes d'affaires dont certains étaient
certainement besoin de plus dont était
douteux que les français il faut qu'il
le sache ce sont les français qui
paieront la recapitalisation du crédit
lyonnais avec leur argent jean-marie le
pen et bernard tapie ne reste même pas
deux minutes pour conclure donc vous
avez commencé à parler le premier vous
comme vous parlerai le dernier jeu
mauvais simplement pour conclure de nous
dire mais en quelques mots votre
française et la france dont nous rêvons
c'est une france qui réussissent à
vaincre le chômage a retrouvé ses
marques en quelque sorte en diminuant le
nombre des immigrés qui seront chez elle
en rétablissant la sécurité
comme cela doit être fait par une
rigueur et une rigueur d'ailleurs de la
formation de l'éducation et il nous
paraît que c'est la reconstruction de la
famille qui doit être la base de la
reconstitution de la moralité dans
l'état et je crois que la france a les
moyens en coopération avec une europe
confédérale par exemple les moyens de
donner à son peuple comme elle l'a fait
pendant 1500 ans la liberté la sécurité
la prospérité
cela c'est un objectif et d'ailleurs
nous le symbolise ont dans notre liste
par le terme allez la france c'est à
l'espoir que nous appelons la jeunesse
et les électeurs et les électrices
français votre france révèle en attaque
et thomas d'abord allez allez allez tout
proche elle est toute proche il
suffirait de pas grand chose d'abord
qu'on arrête de véhiculer ses idées là
parce que ces idées là c'est pas ça
qu'on casse est passée idée là qu'on
fait là vendeur la france deuxièmement
une aristocratie technocratique a pris
tous les pouvoirs à un tous les pouvoirs
et qui est incompatible avec nos vraies
vertus non vertus nous c'est pas
l'organisation la méthode la statistique
c'est pas ça l'ouverture française vous
savez ce que c'est c'est l'imagination
c'est la créativité c'est l'impertinence
c'est l'espoir c'est le rêve c'est
l'utopie c'est ça qu'a fait la france
c'est pas le raisonnement alors moi je
vais vous dire je crois que ces gens là
ont leur place mais ils doivent pas voir
toute la place et si c'est pas un peu de
leur place à des gens qu'on s'évertue la
de la créativité d'imagination on n'aura
pas la france dont on doit rêver qu est
une france heureuse optimiste qu'on en
compte dès qu'on lui fait confiance à un
petit mot ça c'est le livre de bernard
tapie c'est son programme c'est ce qu'il
va faire du moins le dit il ça ce sont
les discours qui ont été prononcées par
nos députés pendant ses discours
monsieur
jean des discours qui donne des pistes
vous êtes élu
vous ne citez pas le conseil des jeunes
a affirmé
qu un jour positif j'ai offert un
compliment à tous les deux vous savez
que vous allez progresser
89 ou débat sur tf1 bernard tapie c'est
pas parce que vous avez une grande
gueule que vous priez fort que vous
arrivez s'adresse à vous jean marie le
pen à bernard tapie je vous écrasez vous
êtes un pitre ce soir
kenzy quelle dignité de richard de se
voir beaucoup je parle pas des
spectateurs
[Musique]